good for you that you get to see this
again crank up the volume
for the biggest event of the summer oh
come on
Guardians laugh out loud funny exactly
you idiots oh no the perfect conclusion
of the Guardians Trilogy it's good to
have friends it's the best Marvel movie
since end game
so that happens
Guardians of the Galaxy volume three
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like Marvel Studios is no
longer stuck it looks like Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 gets Marvel Studios out
of the rut that it has been in and is
back to making amazing quality films we
have some reviews and reactions in four
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. Marvel
Studios has been promoting Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 over in Europe they've
had some premieres already and they've
had some fan screenings as well and
people have shared their reviews and
their reactions online more than just
what we saw in that quick little teaser
from Marvel Studios and what's really
awesome is that most of these reviews a
vast majority of them are really good
however the ones that aren't necessarily
all that good are pretty interesting
specifically mentioning new characters
so we'll dive into what these review
said in this video but first if you love
Marvel Comics and DC Comics I want to
tell you all about my buddies over at
comicbookdirect.com they have created a
website and company that makes comic
book shopping the easiest it can
possibly be they deliver Comics straight
to your door you can get one-off Comics
or you can sign up for an entire run and
get a pretty big discount if you do so
and they'll ship the latest issue right
to your door each week they have the
latest from Marvel if you're trying to
keep up to date with all the recent
projects they have the latest from DC as
well and it's an all-in-one shop for
your Comics everything that you need in
one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below now just alone in the little
teaser that Marvel Studios has given us
on their official YouTube page and on
Instagram and Twitter we've already
heard reviews that are very simple and
one-worded reviews like epic
breathtaking incredible striking
thrilling brilliant entertaining and and
again of course coming from people who
have seen the movie more quick reviews
include laugh out loud funny amazing
spectacular Sublime moving and we're
gonna get into that but some people have
called it the perfect conclusion and
some longer reactions and reviews that
we're about to get into talk about how
this is actually kind of a Dark
Guardians of the Galaxy film but at the
same time it still has those comedic
aspects to it of course but one of the
biggest quotes that sticks out is from
Pepe France and they said that it's the
best Marvel movie since end game which
is a big statement now I know there's a
big group of people out there a big
crowd of the audience who have been
disappointed with Marvel since phase 4
and of course with Phase 5 with Ant-Man
so this should mean a lot to those
people now don't get me wrong I know
there's a lot of people out there who
have pretty much loved everything Marvel
has done still and that is fantastic but
either way no matter which side you're
on these reviews make Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 sound like one of the best
Marvel movies that we've gotten so let's
take a look at these longer reviews Emil
franchi from absolute radio said this
after seeing it twice I can safely say
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 completes
the perfect MCU Trilogy it's
heartbreaking and hilarious and I've
Loved this team from the first ugashaka
a blast for 10 years now we knew that it
was going to be hilarious this part is
definitely known but one thing that Amil
says in his review is that it's
heartbreaking and you're gonna see a lot
of this as we go through more reviews
and keep in mind this probably has to do
with deaths no spoilers in this video of
course they cannot tweet out or post any
type of spoilers and I see this movie on
Thursday and I can post my actual review
on Friday so keep an eye out for my
reaction and then my review but the fact
that so many of these reviews and
reactions already say heartbreaking gets
us concerned about who is going to die
now Mado and I apologize if I don't get
some of these names right from
Crunchyroll news said this Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 is my favorite of the
trilogy promo plus humor mastered each
character shines solo to evolve as a
team the cameos of James Gunn's friends
are funny and the only problem is Adam
Warlock but this is his first film in
short best Marvel since four or five
films so this review states that this is
the best Guardians film out of the three
that we have and that's really saying
something because it is really hard to
make a second film just as good or
better as the first let alone a third
film that's actually pretty rare most
sequels don't do as well as the first
one but here we have somebody stating
that Guardians 3 is their favorite
here's another interesting one Lily La
for me says this movie my heart is full
and broken at the same time it was a lot
to process a very complex story but it
left me feeling awesome so she says her
heart is full and broken at the same
time again I think these people are
referring to some deaths but people
people have also said that this is the
perfect ending for the Guardians Trilogy
so clearly something really great does
happen at the end and I'm guessing that
something great is probably with rocket
we have been told that this movie really
is to kind of wrap up the story of not
just the guardians but specifically
rocket he's the one that gets kidnapped
by the high evolutionary and his stories
coming to an end as he faces the high
evolutionary I still don't know if I
think he's gonna die or survive but I
think the happiness and the Heart
Brokenness could be both about rocket he
could get a happy ending but he could
still die which sounds contradictory but
it could definitely still happen Stephen
of Les dosier's geek and again so sorry
if I'm not pronouncing these right said
this
spoiler free review Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 is my favorite more mature more
violent but still in the DNA of the
Guardians staging level I wanted to
shout voila Marvel finally this film is
doing a lot of good for mixed fans of
the latest projects again another review
stating that Guardians 3 is the best one
and Steven particularly said that this
film is doing a lot of good for mixed
fans of the latest projects that's for
all of the people who have basically
been stating that Marvel has been kind
of mid lately and nothing too
spectacular and here's yet another one
from Marvel's story of France they say
James Gunn leaves with honors Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 is the most touching
and the best realized of the trilogy a
very good conclusion for this endearing
Guardians team and how good it is for
the MCU so another one stating that this
film definitely has something above the
other two in some aspects at least and
yet another one stating that this movie
is good for the MCU meaning it is above
what we've gotten recently now in
regards to Adam Warlock there are some
good comments about him digital spies
Ian Samwell stated Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 is a brilliant end to a
brilliant Trilogy it's very funny
emotional and everybody gets their
standout moment will poulter's warlock
is a terrific addition yet the focus is
rightly on telling a satisfying end for
the Guardians gonna miss them so here's
a review stating that Adam Warlock is
actually good it's a good character and
another review stating that everybody
kind of gets their moment which is great
because this is the end for a lot of
them so it looks like James Gunn of
course really put a lot into this
because he knew it was going to be the
last one so he made sure that this film
did Justice to not only the Guardians
team but each individual character that
makes up the Guardians and of course
villains as well but it sounds like you
should be prepared to cry Alexander
cardello from movie Zion said this
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 is more than
ever Star Wars as a stoner comedy
lovable weirdos big Marvel action and
Goofy jokes but nothing can prepare you
for all the emotions rocket raccoon's
origin story is beautiful and
heart-wrenching a German journalist
Marcus trutt said this Guardians 3 is
probably the saddest and darkest MCU
film and a wonderfully rounded
conclusion to guns Trilogy where
everyone in the fight against a mean but
rather shallow villain gets their big
moment again have tissues ready so
basically what we've been hearing is
that Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is an
amazing movie and it is definitely the
end for the Guardians and some of them
are going to die and that's going to be
pretty heart-wrenching for a lot of
people it's gonna be sad it's going to
be dark and of course that is probably
because of the high evolutionary of
course he's going to be experimenting on
people and will see him experiment on
little baby Rocket Raccoon so that's
dark but it still does have that same
classic Guardians of the Galaxy goofy
action adventure ride so this should
give Marvel fans hope that Marvel
Studios is about to pick it back up and
start making nothing but amazing movies
again hopefully fingers crossed and
again I see this Thursday night at the
LA Premiere so be sure to hit that
notification Bell because I'll be
posting my reaction right when I get out
of the theater and a review the next day
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and leave a comment down below so you
can enter our giveaway we're giving away
a PS5 a Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items winner
gets to pick and we pick a winner at the
end of each month don't forget to follow
us on Instagram and Twitter as well and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
foreign